Good Morning Starshine power Beauty foam
primer
like how satisfied
you have the ability to influence the
world
in many ways ways that could be great
anyways that could be ugly
now we see that there's an ugliness to
this all I ask is do the right thing to
do the right thing
Tick Tock is one of the most popular
social media platforms that exists today
almost 70 percent of kids between the
ages of 13 to 17 are on tick tock on a
daily basis using it more than all of
those other platforms that have existed
in our lives
one of their greatest strengths is that
it's so popular for kids but that has
also become one of its biggest
weaknesses
not only do you have some of the
youngest users in the world of social
media we're also seeing content that is
proliferating through the app that can
be potentially harmful to kids we're
seeing disordered eating content we're
seeing posts about suicide and self-harm
we're also seeing dangerous and in some
cases deadly challenges
I'm so protective of the outside I never
thought I'd have to be protective of the
inside a social media app I never
thought in my mind that that could ever
Resort using my daughter
I am here because I don't want any more
children to die I don't want any mother
or father to feel the pain and the
heartache
and the Brokenness that we feel every
single day because this is hard
[Music]
one of the biggest issues that Tick Tock
is facing today is the Blackout
Challenge this is a challenge where
children are choking themselves until
they lose Consciousness and then filming
the adrenaline rush they get when they
wake up
involves individuals holding their
breath we have seen a number of children
die participating in this challenge
across the United States and also around
the world
now we're seeing lawsuits being filed
against Tick Tock raising the question
of who is responsible who is liable for
these deaths
the only thing that's certain about this
case is the incredible opposition that
we're going to face at every step of the
way the last thing in the world these
companies want to do is stand up in
front of a jury and explain to them why
their profits were more important than
life
our entire Society is bleeding and our
children are dying and unless we do
something to change that this is going
to keep happening
I do what are you going to do to change
this platform because at this point it's
not safe for anyone and it's definitely
not safe for any child
for the last 25 years my practice has
focused on compensating victims who are
injured by corporate misconduct
I've recovered over a billion dollars on
behalf of families who've lost loved
ones most of my cases have involved
asbestos victims
I wanted to do something
not simply to compensate victims but to
see if I could use a legal system to
have less victims in the first place
Francis Haugen released her papers on
what the social media companies knew and
that reminded me of what the asbestos
companies knew only worse the choices
being made inside of Facebook are
disastrous
for our children for our Public Safety
for our privacy and for our democracy
we can have social media we enjoy we can
do better these companies make the
asbestos companies look like choir boys
these companies know that children are
being injured as they speak right now
and more importantly they continue to
Target children through their algorithms
the goal is to addict children to their
products
yeah
children are being directed toward
material that they don't want to see for
purposes of Engagement that's what these
algorithms are designed to do
the social media victims Law Center is
based in Seattle it's a small team of
lawyers that are taking on the biggest
companies in the world filing cases
against social media platforms their
cases include suicide on the apps
children who have attempted the Blackout
Challenge and tragically died or kids
who have been sent down eating
disordered rabbit holes who have ended
up in hospital over the content that
they've been served through tiktok and
other platforms
what the center is really hoping to
achieve is to push social media
companies to accept a level of
responsibility over these cases and put
children's best interests in front of
profit
corporate misconduct is knowingly
putting profits over people it's knowing
that your products hurt kids
and knowing that you could make them
better and intentionally making the
decision not to do so because it would
impair their profits that to me is
corporate misconduct
I think that as long as you have a
profit model that is built first last
and in the middle on user engagement
above and beyond all things I think it's
inevitable that you're going to have
these kind of Hazards and these kind of
outcomes
my clients feel like if through this
effort one child is saved then it's been
worth it
we're in Milwaukee Wisconsin and I've
come down here to talk to the family of
ariani Arroyo
she was a nine-year-old girl who loved
Tick Tock and in February last year she
was trying the Blackout Challenge and
she tragically died
earlier this month July of 2022 her
family filed a wrongful death lawsuit
against Tech talk
think the question of responsibility and
liability of these social media
platforms is a really big one and I
think this family is you know wanting to
raise that question what kind of
liability
does tick tock have when it's young
users try these viral challenges and
they have fatal consequences
seems like a really
nice quaint
suburban area
so sad
eggy eggy it's time to eat
oh I brought you in there give me that
one
you have that
is it warm
good
I love you
oh okay what
ADI she had this personality that wasn't
afraid to like
Take On The World she wasn't afraid to
take on a challenge she wasn't afraid to
do whatever she felt she wanted to do
yeah she she loved to sing um in her
room and I mean you can hear her
sing out of her lungs just singing
Alicia Keys this girl's on fire that was
her song it was I mean over and over it
would be you could hear her singing her
lungs out she was just so beautiful too
beautiful sometimes I think we live in
such an ugly world that
she's too beautiful
why do you think Tick Tock was so
intriguing to her
I go back to the dancing and the singing
and it was not just that all her friends
all her peers everybody's doing the
trends it's on TV Tic Tac was for
everybody and it wasn't just a kid thing
it was an adult thing it was a teenage
thing I mean it was it was just a known
app she's nine years old she's still a
little kid and uh
curious we talked to her many times
before about things like that
and we've also even warned her of things
so we did we thought we were on great
track it's not something that we
would say it'd be any harm or dangerous
to her it's a phone
prior to her death
how long she'd spend on tick tock
every day
every single day
don't care about what other people say
about you be confident and be possible
because everyone in this world is
beautiful so
social media challenges really started
spreading throughout the pandemic when
kids were unable to be in school they
were in isolation at home and they were
turning to social media to connect with
their peers and we saw some really cool
challenges pop up
but as is always typical when kids are
involved and when social media is
involved some of these challenges
started to get edgier they started to
get a bit more dangerous I was
in January 2021 we saw the first death
associated with a challenge called the
Blackout Challenge
this challenge has existed for decades
now we have children filming themselves
doing it and it's spreading across
social media which is encouraging some
of the youngest users on the platform to
try this game or this challenge without
realizing that it can be deadly
[Music]
um this is adiani right there that's her
I wear this with me on most occasions
you you you think of the happy moments
you think of the beautiful memories but
the fact that you're never gonna create
them again we're all just very broken as
a family you know
Ariana Arroyo was playing with her
four-year-old brother when she
accidentally hanged herself
she'd been asking her parents for months
to get a dog and they'd finally agreed
and they'd bought a metal dog leash to
show their children that they were
willing to to get a puppy and Ariana and
her brother were playing with this dog
leash she wrapped it around her neck and
hooked the Buckle onto the hinge of a
wardrobe door
she then slipped off a toy chest and
couldn't escape
their dad then came upstairs and saw
ariani lifeless he called the paramedics
but sadly she never regained
consciousness
she was buried in a tiara and a fairy
princess dress with her nails freshly
painted
her parents believe that tiktok's
algorithm fed the Blackout Challenge to
ariani on her cell phone
we are not living we are surviving
because every day we wake up and we're
not hearing her say I love you we're not
hugging her we're not holding her and
anybody
that has to go through what we've
experienced that's what's going to be
the outcome and we're here to make sure
that there is education where in God's
name did you think that
putting a rope around your neck a chain
around your neck is something wise to
put out there
and reality is I feel that like
everybody
they should be held accountable for
their actions
my daughter is gone
other kids are gone there's darker sides
to tick tock than what they're exposing
why did you decide that you wanted to
file a lawsuit against Tech talk for
wrongful death
well first yeah they're responsible I
feel that they're responsible for it
second of all we need to right now we
need to save every other child that's
out there
they need
to make changes and because other kids
can be still vulnerable for this
I think it's really important to
remember that Tech talk doesn't want the
Blackout Challenge to exist on its
platform and it has taken steps to try
and remove content so way back in
January of 2021 after the first child's
death was linked to the Blackout
Challenge and connected to tiktok the
company decided to scrub the ability to
search for Blackout Challenge content on
the app they have updated their
Community guidelines to say they ban any
kind of content that glorifies dangerous
or harmful Behavior they have also
trained their moderators to look out for
Blackout Challenge or other dangerous
challenges that are spreading across
their sites they are removing this
content but despite all these safety
measures the deaths kept happening we
found that the Blackout Challenge was
cited as the cause of more than a dozen
deaths of children throughout 2021 and I
think the the biggest legal question for
all of these lawsuits that we're seeing
coming up in the courts today day is can
you prove that tick tock's algorithm
sent that Blackout Challenge content to
the child's phone
this is her chest where are her
some of her stuff
this is her birth announcement
these are her third grade
photos
I know it's been almost two years but it
just still feels like yesterday
it just
it's a
it's a feeling that just takes the the
breath out of you it takes it is a
heaviness on your chest
grief is
is so hard and everything I do is just
like
really reflects off of what I feel she
would want me to do
and I really believe that this fight
is because that's what she would want me
to do
and that's why I'm fighting for her and
all these kids
because I believe that's what she would
want
so Tick Tock was created in 2016 by bite
dance a big company based out of China
it actually took a while for it to gain
traction
it wasn't until 2018 that Tick Tock
really blew up and that was because bite
dance bought this lip syncing app called
musically and at the time musically had
about 200 million users many of these
were under the age of 13. this violated
the children's online privacy protection
act which is a law that says children
under the age of 13 you can't collect
their data
in order to abide by all of these
regulations tiktok has created a version
of its app in the US that is targeted to
kids under the age of 13 and it's called
Tick Tock for younger users
it really tailors the content to be
suitable to kids and it doesn't Target
them with advertising but kids know how
to get around it they just enter the
wrong date of birth
Tech talk will tell us that age
Assurance is an industry-wide issue but
in the last year we've seen a number of
companies partner with third-party
content moderation providers what these
providers can do is run machine learning
age prediction models that isn't
collecting any data on the individual it
doesn't raise privacy concerns but what
it does do is estimate how old that user
is and is highly efficient
I sent a video of Ariana Arroyo to Hive
this is one of those artificial
intelligence content moderation
companies that does age prediction for
other big platforms like Twitter and
Reddit and it took hive's technology
three seconds to estimate that ariani
was 10 years old she died just three
months shy of her 10th birthday
has also met with these third-party
content moderation providers they
ultimately decided not to deploy this
technology because there were fears it
could Stoke further suspicions around
China spying on young users
wow wow okay is that something that you
can share you know what what I say is
that the way these products were
designed it was impossible for parents
to exercise a meaningful oversight of
their of their children
what's occurring now is when an
economist would call an externality the
costs of these unsafe social media
products are borne by parents they're
born by teachers they're born by law
enforcement medical providers
psychologists clergy the costs are not
being borne by the entities making the
product we think that product liability
provides a independent way to hold these
companies accountable not for publishing
third-party content but for Designing
algorithms that hurt kids if they
actually have to pay the cost of their
dangerous products they are going to
have the economic incentive to design
safer products
cars are a lot safer than they were in
1950 they're a lot more safer than they
were in 1980 and a big reason for that
is that the concept of product liability
creates the incentive on automobile
manufacturers to think proactively to
design safer products and and it is our
hope that the same thing can be done
here and that five years from now
children will be having positive
experiences on social media and that
these horrific outcomes like Ariana
Arroyo will have stopped
this whole situation has placed us in a
and uh you know everything's almost like
red flags you know Eduardo going to
school again he's going by himself it's
another thought we don't know what the
long-term effect is on him you know
you're doing the best you can and that's
all you can do that's all yeah
and you know we've got a long road ahead
of us but we've already made a
difference and you've already made the
difference you've already blessed a lot
of people through her memory
I think it is the most innate
human
emotion is protecting your kids these
were parents that thought they were
doing the right thing thought they were
being responsible and then just the
profound guilt that these parents are
feeling is unfathomable
hi baby
baby
social media has been designed to put
things out there to put content out
there to make kids believe that either
they're not enough or they're not good
enough or they have to be this way
[Music]
these challenges
I feel just like manipulate the mind to
think like if I can conquer this if I
can do this you know I have purpose
you don't need none of that to have
purpose in life we need to as parents
remind our children what purpose is and
and help them and direct them to finding
their real purpose in life because
social media is not it
these social media companies are giant
billion dollar goliaths and they will
all claim that safety is their number
one priority
but when you speak to insiders to those
who work on trust and safety teams
tasked with keeping these platforms safe
the message I hear time and time again
is that user safety is not the number
one priority that growth is the number
one priority making more money is the
number one priority and being the
biggest app in the world is the number
one priority that's true of tech talk
and that's true of other social media
platforms as well
as we've seen more and more children be
harmed through the social media we're
now starting to ask have these companies
been doing enough
do they really want to protect and keep
their users safe or are they just doing
the bare minimum to avoid being held
liable against existing privacy laws
children have been dying using these
platforms and these questions aren't
going to stop
foreign